these are longer innovation pages
because their equations which involve
more rhythms right but they're very
simple because essentially what you end
up with is something linear to solve
okay and you'll see what I mean this is
just your standard your stock standard
motivation how shall we rewrite it in
this ebook it's all good
x equals your base stays the same and
what was the subject before six is the
power so of course that's just 64 no
problems all right that's about as easy
as it gets
okay this is like your warmup question
right and when you can't have to hear
all this is is just another log equation
right but it's a quadratic in a one
function okay so you've got a log
function squared minus now we need to
use one of our log laws here to rework
this how shall I do it what could I use
good just to write it could be a three
or four or five or anything it really
belongs out the front very huge so it's
gonna become log base two of X all
squared minus two log base two of X now
if you find it a little bit like your
brain is kind of weirding out when you
see that that's okay the easiest thing
that I would suggest you do to me
obvious what's happening and it's
optional I put on the plus side is to
say you can let u equal log base two of
X okay and so you've got really it's u
squared minus 2-u minus 8 you don't need
to do that you might be able to see okay
I want pair of numbers they add two
minus two they multiply two by this a
the pair of numbers is
Thank You negative four and positive two
so when I factorize this this is what I
get for 2x minus 4 2 X plus 2 you're
happy with that
that makes it so much okay sure offer
this factorization I have two solutions
to this right
I have either have log base 2 of X be
equal to 4 or I have log base 2 of X
equal to negative 2
okay now don't confuse yourself right
you can see thing is but is it okay if
this is where they belong
think about how we did this first
question and what these bead need index
for this one open it X is equal to it's
2 to the 4 which is 16
okay and here this is 2 to the negative
2 everyone over to sweat so that's
that's a quarter okay sir no problems
right even though this is a quadratic
once you get down to this point what you
have to solve is linear like this part
one solution this part one solution so
far so good